[Music]
did you receive a briefing about the
border today
uh yes i did what did you learn
a lot
okay god willing president biden there
yesterday argued that the surge at our
southern border is not a crisis
his denial comes amid reports projecting
1000 or rather 117 000
unaccompanied child migrants are
expected to cross into this year that's
forty five percent higher than the most
we've ever had in a single year
and the administration doesn't have
enough of beds available
they're asking for another twenty
thousand here at the reaction texas
congressman dan crenshaw dan good
morning to you
good morning good to know it's not a
crisis at our southern border although
as we just heard from griff jenkins
apparently all these people who are
being released by the federal government
into the united states something like
at least six percent of them have
coveted but we can't stop them
yeah and it's the usual euphemisms to
cover up their lives right it's not a
crisis it's a challenge it's not a cage
it's a soft-sided structure
and uh look this is this is the truth
and everybody needs to understand this
the democrats and joe biden they want
more illegal immigrants crossing our
border
they want this now in the past they
always used to say no it's
we want border security it's just that
we don't want trump's big dumb wall
well you know we shouldn't believe them
because as soon as joe biden took office
he ripped up agreements with mexico the
the very agreements that were stopping
this border crisis he ripped up
agreements with the northern triangle
countries
ripped up those asylum agreements and
now everybody and you could see in
interviews people coming in caravans to
the u.s as biden was getting inaugurated
saying
new president now here we come and this
is exactly what happens they've
reinstituted the practice of catch and
release
you just you guys are just playing that
uh on your show
there's lines and lines of people okay
they're just waiting to come in you know
who they're cutting in front of
legal immigrants legal immigrants my
stepmother is a legal immigrant who
waited years to come to this country
many many friends who were legally who
legally immigrated to this country they
did it the right way
and guess what here's what's even most
infuriating about the covid
uh positive cases that you just
mentioned u.s citizens have to get a
negative test
uh before coming in back into our
country this administration is
prioritizing illegal immigrants over u.s
citizens
and according to axios yesterday they
had a blockbuster report that said
that joe biden was being told yesterday
afternoon that
it you know it's not a crisis but it's
really a catastrophe
where they need 20 000 more beds because
there are so many kids at our southern
border
they're starting to relax uh the vetting
of who can sponsor them in the country
and they're going to start taking off
yeah you got to put down your social
security number if you're going to be a
sponsor
because they are so desperate to get
people out of the door
and get them into the country in fact
some of those people who were in the
story that griff was talking about in
brownsville texas
they apparently told the nbc station
down there
that they were going to texas they were
going to north carolina
maryland new jersey and who else knows
who knows where else they're going to
travel during their
exposure to covet while they're still
infected
exactly look what immediately needs to
happen is they need to reinstitute the
migrant protection protocols which is
the remaining mexico policy
this single action by the trump
administration almost single-handedly
dropped uh illegal crossings because
what is it does it says
a portion of the illegal crossings on
any given day get sent right back to
mexico city and if they're claiming
asylum and most of these asylum claims
let's be honest are totally bogus
they're not being persecuted in any way
that meets the standard for an asylum
case
but it creates a disincentive to just
cross
because they know they're going to have
to be sent right back to mexico when you
just say hey if you cross
well we'll just give you a bus ticket
anywhere you want no matter what kind of
covid you have doesn't really matter of
course there's a massive incentive for
thousands and thousands more people
to come across and they drag children
with them and guess what
here's the worst part about this this
encourages child trafficking
a lot of times i talk to a lot of border
agents they see these kids just recycled
over and over again because these adults
know
all they need is a kid with them yeah
indeed we were just talking about what's
going on in your home state of texas
governor
abbott yesterday got rid of all the
restrictions on a statewide basis
and i know mass and everything else uh
you've introduced anti-lockdown
legislation to
end the shutdown during the pandemic i
think it's called the end lockdowns now
act that's pretty clear what that's
about
it is look and it's based on this single
premise lockdowns don't work they don't
work
study after study after study has shown
this we have a year's worth of data
right now one of the most recent came
out of stanford
and it concluded there is no additional
benefit to stay at home orders no
additional benefits to closing
businesses
so you have an extremely high cost
action with no benefit right
coded happens it's a pandemic i don't
know why the left can't understand this
they're in love with lockdowns they're
in love with mandates
uh they believe that that is their
savior because they're anti-science the
left is anti-science on this they don't
listen to the data they don't listen to
the science
and so i have a bill that it's not
federal overreach either right it ties
federal relief money to a reopening plan
and this is especially important with
when you've got citizens in california
new york who are being destroyed by
their government
they have no reopening plan they have no
light at the end of the tunnel and yet
they're asking for federal taxpayer
money
the second part of the bill says look
the president cannot unilaterally
lock down the country as joe biden had
said that he
would want to do luckily never did but
now we put it into law
all right let's see what happens with
that congressman thank you very much for
joining us today from dc
thanks for having me all right